the host I'm gonna be a straight to the
point as possible on this review those
is a pretty bad movie it's awful if
you're looking for a movie with really
bad dialogue sometimes so expositional
that the director is practically calling
you an idiot and a film loaded with
unintentional laughs then you'll love
the host no they have to know the truth
sometimes it's so cheesy and awkward
that you actually feel uncomfortable to
watch the screen because clearly
everyone involved is taking it seriously
I imagine that's what it feels like when
r kelly pisses on you sometimes it's so
bad it's good rarely though is it boring
Saoirse Ronan saoirse ronan saris Ronin
who the [ __ ] cares plays Melanie or is
it one or is it wanderer I'm trying as
Wanda she's actually quite good in the
role but as the character Melanie which
is essentially a voiceover in her head
Melanie behaves like a 13 year old [ __ ]
the age of the character does not match
the dialogue in her head sometimes you
really want her to shut the [ __ ] up then
there's a romantic three-way story yes
Stephanie miner really wants a threesome
between this [ __ ] and this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] what's
the bang Melanie this [ __ ] is
falling in love with Wanda the alien
none of the romantic elements are felt
they're actually the worst parts of this
film some romantic moments are so weird
dye actually said at one point oh my god
what the [ __ ] am i watching and as far
as water goes she's quite possibly the
[ __ ] alien I've ever seen even more
[ __ ] than natasha Henstridge in
species I'd still bang her I'll try
there's actually some really good
cinematography but people hate on me
William Hurt is actually really good in
this movie as a protective uncle of
Melanie
some of the designs were really cool but
the contacts on the aliens was really
distracting I don't know I have really
mixed emotions about the movie you're
right i'm horny oh I actually love the
film's concept the whole time I was
watching it I was thinking with a good
rewrite this could be an excellent
picture there's a lot of strong elements
that could work with from the
science-fiction elements to the
exploration of humanity to the action
the drama the complexity the world so
much great stuff in it but its execution
delivers an entire cheeseball fest okay
the whole thing is not bad there's some
moments that I really did enjoy that
really hit the mark honestly I thought
it was better than twilight that's what
she said I can honestly say for the most
part I was entertained throughout
despite the whole time I was thinking
this could be a better movie I actually
really like the flick well I have to
think have had the majority of people
will react to the movie let me get
straight to the point here oh no I gotta
say the host got it wrong p
alright guys thanks for checking out my
video go ahead and scroll to that
comment box and tell me your points
below and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of the host go ahead and
check out my show called the reasons to
see that I do with my buddy Jerry or
will give you reasons to see and not to
see is the host and last but not least
if you want to get updated every time a
new review is out go ahead and subscribe
to my channel on the link right there